well guys I actually got a free poster
for Sparkle at the screening Sparkle it
stars Jordin Sparks Whitney Houston and
some other people as well it's a story
about this young girl Sparkle played by
Jordin Sparks II her name's Sparkle just
really you know that her mom named her
Sparkle Sparkle has a beautiful voice
she writes her own songs her mom is
played by Whitney Houston she has two
sisters who also sing very well
her mom is very strict you know very
hardcore religious upbringing you know I
don't want you to sing when they get the
opportunity to go out and sing in some
clubs the three of them start this band
together led by the oldest sister
Sparkle singing backup and along their
journey they find love and despair and
drugs and all different types of things
as they learn what it's like to be in
the music business all the while they're
trying to hide all this from their
extremely strict mother now I saw this
movie for one reason and one reason only
this is unfortunately Whitney Houston's
last performance the poor thing
unfortunately passed away earlier this
year I liked her songs I think she had a
beautiful voice she was probably the
best singers ever and you know there's
been a real string of just mediocrity
lately where every film has just been
like can sparkle and this string of
mediocre movies yes actually it can this
movie's not mediocre it's god-awful I
can't hide it I'm not gonna make any
ands ifs or buts about it this is a
horrible movie every single turn is 100%
predictable and all the different ways
possible it is such a cliched story it
is horrendously cliched and like I said
in many reviews in the past cliches
don't bother me if the film can present
them in a new way or surprise me in some
kind of way in which these various
cliches or tropes of whatever genre the
film is are presented this film does not
do that it has everything you could
possibly think of being this movie and
it treats them all in such a fake
horribly fake way one of the things that
surprised me most about this movie is
there's this big subplot involving
domestic abuse with one of the sisters
and you can see it coming a mile away
it's like the biggest red light ever is
right there in front of this girl and
she is so stupid this character she just
goes right forth into it oh there it is
yep yep you're getting beat up what do
you think that's gonna happen
but the biggest problem with that is
that it is told and directed so poorly
then the audience was actually laughing
at the partisan which that was supposed
to be serious they weren't able to
understand how serious it was and that's
the fault of the director and the
writers it was so poorly told the
audience members were laughing at
domestic abuse when the audience is
laughing at physical abuse you know it's
bad it's Jordin Sparks the talented
singer I got nothing against her but I
got to speak the truth she was horrible
in this movie her acting was awful her
performance was so bad and I can't even
really fault it because this script it's
like there's nothing you know it's like
there's nothing there it's when you're
an actor and you're fed lines that are
this atrocious it's like what else can
you do but seem incredibly fake because
what you're reading is incredibly fake
I called the twilight syndrome okay you
have actors in Twilight who have talent
they have proven it in past films some
of them anyway but they can't do
anything about that because the script
is so bad that their performances are
going to be horrible no matter what they
do Sparkle has the Twilight problem it
can't get away from it no matter how
good of an actor you may be inside these
actors are reading dialogue that it's
like fifth grade just some road it's
scribbled on a piece of paper of cram
it's so bad if you want to see this
movie you're obviously a fan of some of
the people in it whether it be Jordin
Sparks our Whitney Houston or someone
else in the film and you want to hear
them sing you're gonna get that and
they're good at it
they're great singers they're obviously
singers not actors - one Whitney Houston
now this is gonna sound really forced
coming for me since unfortunately she
did pass away and I was a fan of her
music she was literally the only good
thing in this movie her performance was
actually good she was good in the movie
and when she sang in the movie beautiful
fantastic her voice is amazing and it
was the most riveting scene in the
entire movie and it's actually the only
scene that actually gave me goosebumps
she was the only character that I
actually felt had some sort of depth to
her and it wasn't just because of her
performance like she actually had a
backstory everyone else in this movie
just was kind of there and with no real
depth or any character development at
all Whitney Houston was good in this
movie her singing was still great and I
miss her as a talent she was great you
know she had a lot of problems in life
but who doesn't they try to shoehorn
this whole incredibly forced plot with
drug addiction in there of course
because this is a movie about rising
singer
of course they got to do drugs for some
reason no one ever just became a singer
and decided not to do cocaine every
singer ever became famous and they was
like you know what I'm gonna do cocaine
and it's one of those movies where the
characters are so stupid where they say
things and they do things and you're
like why are you doing that that's
horrible there's no reason to say that
right now I'm being hard on this movie
cuz it sucks I mean it's it is really i
rollin ly bad if you already want to see
this movie if you're a fan of Jordin
Sparks or Whitney Houston and you just
want to see this movie to hear them sing
you're gonna like it more than likely if
you've been watching my reviews for a
while you have no interest in this film
I don't blame you because I went and saw
it because this is what I do I do this
for you guys I like talking about
horrible movies too and I got it it's
fun no it's fun to talk about movies
like this where you can just like uh uh
just get stuff out of you you know awful
direction that continuously repeats the
exact same motion of just showing a
woman's face and then panning down to
her hips as she shakes them I cannot
tell you how many times in this movie it
shows a woman's face and then pans down
to her gyrating hips not something I
don't mind seeing that's fine but it's
like after a while it was just can you
do anything stylistic with your
direction at all or are you just gonna
make this a giant one big two-hour long
music video it's all just bad it's a bad
bad movie I'm giving Sparkle a d-minus
because Whitney Houston was good in the
film I wouldn't see it but more than
likely you're not going to anyway and as
always guys thanks for watching if you
liked this review you can subscribe to
my channel and get stuck mine eyes